we've seen interpolation which is within
your set of data an extrapolation can be
immensely useful for being able to work
out trends being able to get to data you
do not have access to because you're
only measure at discrete points in time
but of course all of your predictions
they all fall prey to the same problem
which is if you're just looking at a set
of data and then like eyeballing a line
through it well you've seen some of the
answers and you compared you're like oh
mine is different to theirs mine is even
different to the person next to me right
so we need to do this more precisely but
thankfully we have the tools to do this
now in your booklet if you flick forward
a few pages three or four pages ish you
can see this little heading this has
using technology now the technology that
you guys are expected to be able to
master is of course your scientific
calculator so grab it out there and I'm
gonna show you how to get to this line
of best fit which you can use for
interpolation and extrapolation but do
it much more accurately now we're going
to start off and I think it's good to
refresh our memory from this one last
way we're going to start off by first
entering the data we've done this before
so hopefully it's a bit of a um a
reminder for you let's look at exercise
eight one a just that first set of data
there it's just got six data points
right you can see they're listed as
coordinates so let's remember turn
things on make sure you clear everything
just in case you left anything behind
from last time and maybe you guys can
help me remind me how do I get into stat
mode in the first place okay right at
the top there mode very good and on your
calculator it'll be too but I'm mrs.
Liza's fancy calculator which can do
complex numbers and you're like what on
earth the complex numbers it's three but
you guys can say - what do I put when I
get to this screen yeah I want to a plus
BX that tells you it's what kind of data
it's two variables bivariate right so
let's go ahead and hit that you know
you've done it right because you've got
your two columns your X and your Y so
let's just quickly you've got all your
data points then let's make the first
one X the second one Y conveniently your
x-values are one two three four five and
six and then go ahead and import your
y-values
one point seven one point nine and so on
like I have before I'm going to highly
encourage you as soon as you've entered
all your data just scan back up using
the keypad use the arrows to scan back
up through your data and make sure
you've actually entered it correctly
because everything that your calculators
going to tell you in a second is all
based on this data if it's inaccurate
and won't tell you it's inaccurate it'll
just give you the wrong results if
you're happy we give six data points go
ahead and clear that now I want to get
or in this exercise you want Pearson's
correlation coefficient we know how to
get to that in fact that's going to be
the same place where we get this other
information that the questions asking
for so have a look how do I get two
pieces coefficient again shift one cuz
you can see there's stat right there
above the one button okay
Pierce's coefficient it's under which
heading have a look it's it's re G which
stands for do remember I told you all
the steps before it's an abbreviation of
regression okay big fancy word but it's
just about this line of best fit so go
ahead and hit that now don't press
anything yet if I wanted Pearson's
coefficient which would I go for I'd go
for three which is R right
but actually I want to go further than
that you can see this question and what
we've been looking at in extrapolation
interpolation what we're looking for is
really the line of best fit okay now I'm
just gonna pause for a second do you
remember when we selected this mode it
said this do you remember that right now
what is this this is the equation of the
line or best fit there's going to be
this information here which is a
y-intercept and then this what's this
toss coefficient of x it's your gradient
right is it going is it going up is it
going down is it flat okay wouldn't be
very interesting data if it was flat so
the a and the B have a look at your
calculator again aim the B on now what
we're after okay so you can see the
first one there is a if you press one
and then hit equals go ahead and jot
that down on your book cause it's we're
about to erase it so zero point four
four is your a value and once you've got
that written down zero point four four
you then want to clear that and go back
into that regression section so stat5
for a regression and now where's B it's
just the next one over two and then
you'll get another number for that okay
so if you drop both of those down zero
point nine four five seven is what I can
see on mine did I enter my data right if
you got the same number thumbs up okay
fantastic
so once you've written those down what's
that telling us I have a line of best
fit now it's going to be zero point four
four plus what was it zero point nine
four five seven etc yeah okay um X and
we kind of need that that's so important
right now what's great is this is
accurate this is not us guessing in
later it's roughly in the right spot and
I'll prove it to you here's our data set
these are the six data points that you
just put into your calculator okay and
you can go ahead you can verify this in
desmos for the other data sets that you
get what was the equation of the line of
best fit that our calculator was telling
us zero point zero point four four plus
zero point nine four five seven and then
don't forget the sorry five seven don't
forget the X what do I think of that
pretty bang on right now you'll see
later on um you've got lots of data sets
that do exactly this okay
you've got this straight line and it
roughly goes through but you also see as
you turn the pages there'll be other
data sets where a straight line just
won't cut it and so we'll have to look
at different models for that a bit later
on okay so just to refresh your memory
input your data go back into shift one
and then regression to find all of our
these piece of information and you're
good to go